معنا الان من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام مسار المعارك بحسب البيانات
بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي تحديدا في خان
يونس
الياس بالفعل ازدهار والجيش الاسرائيلي
يؤكد منذ ايام بان عملياته او زخم
العمليات العسكريه يتواصل في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا في منطقه خان يونس حيث
تنشط الفرقه 98 على اليتها السبعه المنخرط
في القتال هناك لكن من الواضح بان هذه
العمليات العسكريه وان كانت هي تشهد الزخم
الاكبر مقارنه ربما مع المناطق الاخرى في
قطاع غزه في الوسط او في المناطق الشماليه
لكن هذه العمليات تسير ببطء شديد وبحذر
شديد على اعتبار ان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه العسكريه لدى الاجهزه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه ولدى شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تشير
الى ان الاسرى الاسرائيليين محتجزين في
تلك المناطق لذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
ينشط بالاف الجنود الاسرائيليين ضمن هذه
الالويه يتقدم بشكل حذر
وبرون شديد كما تصف بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في عمليه التقدم والتوغل في
مناطق بعينها في خان يونس على اعتبار ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعمل عسكريا فوق الارض
وتحتها وعندما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
يعمل تحت الارض في هذه المناطق هو يقصد
العمل في الكشف عن مزيد من الانفاق
الهجوميه التي يعتقد الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه موجودين فيها من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
بامكانيه الوصول ايضا الى القيادات العليا
العسكريه والسياسيه لحركه حماس التي تعتقد
اسرائيل انها موجوده في هذه الانفاق
الهجوميه التي تدار من خلالها ايضا
العمليات العسكريه ضد اسرائيل وبالتالي
كان الكشف من جانب المتحدث الرسمي
الاسرائيلي العسكري قبل ايام عن وجو او
العثور على احد الانفاق التي كانت كان
يحتجز فيها نحو 20 اسيرا اسرائيليا في
الاسابيع الماضيه والعثور على بعض
المقتنيات او الحاجيات التي تربط هؤلاء
الاسرى الاسرائيليين بمكان احتجازهم في
هذا في هذا ال النفق الذي كشف عنه قبل
ايام لكن واضح بان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يقول في هذا السياق بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعمل على توسيع نطاق العمليات العسكريه في
منطقه خانيونس وهو يقصد ربما توسيع هذه
العمليات الى مناطقه لم يصلها الجيش
الاسرائيلي من قبل في اطار هذه العمليه
العسكريه لكنه لا يقصد باي بكل تاكيد ربما
الانتقال الى منطقه رفح حيث ان ال الجيش
الاسرائيلي يرى ان تكدس الفلسطينيين في
تلك المناطق تحديدا نحو مليون لاجئ
فلسطيني ممن نزحوا من المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه وتكدس في تلك المناطق تحول دون
الق قيام الجيش الاسرائيلي بعمليه عسكريه
كبرى وامكانيه التقدم ايضا الى المنطقه
الحدوديه مع مع مصر والمعروفه بمحور
فيلادلفيا على اعتبار ان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو كان اكد في تصريح له قبل
ايام بان هذه العمليه العسكريه لن تنتهي
قبل ان يسيطر الجيش الاسرائيلي على هذا
المحور محور فيلا دلفي الذي يفصل عمليا
بين قطاع غزه والاراضي المصريه وواضح بانه
بدون التقدم الى رفح لا يمكن للجيش
الاسرائيلي اولا السيطره على هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه ولا يمكن للجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
السيطره على هذه المنطقه الحدوديه قبل ان
ينسق ذلك مع مع الجانب المصري ومن الواضح
بان الجانب المصري لا يعطي ضوءا اخضرا كما
يبدو لاسرائيل بالتقدم والعمل عسكريا في
تلك المنطقه لذلك تبقى هذه اهدافا بالنسبه
لاسرائيل لكن هي ايضا من ناحيه اخرى وسائل
بيد اسرائيل كما يبدو للضغط على الجانب
الفلسطيني من ناحيه والضغط من ناحيه اخرى
ربما على الدول التي تقوم بالوساطات من
شان اتمام صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى على
اعتبار ان اسرائيل ما زالت تتمسك على
الاقل من ج برئيس وزرائها ووزير دفاع هيو
اف جرانت على ان العمليه العسكريه هي ربما
تشكل الرافعه الوحيده او وسيله الضغط
الوحيده على المقاومه الفلسطينيه من اجل
اتمام صفقه وراينا بالامس ان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو كان رفض ما قال بانها
شروط الاستسلام التي تفرضها حركه حماس على
اسرائيل في التعاطي مع صفقه لتبادل الاسر
والتي تشمل من وجهه نظر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقفا شاملا للعمليات القتاليه
اي وقف وفا للحرب والانسحاب من قطاع غزه
وبطبيعه الحال صفقه تبادل اسرى كبيره تضم
الفلسطينيين الموجودين الاسرى الفلسطينيين
في السجون الاسرائيليه بمن فيهم ايضا
عناصر كتائب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
الذين شاركوا في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
وبقاء حركه حماس على راس السلطه في قطاع
غزه وهذه شروط قال رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو بانه يرفضها جمله وتفصيلا وعم لا
يمكن لاسرائيل ان تقبل بها على الاطلاق
وهذا هو ربما ازدهار ما يفسر الغضب الشديد
من جانب عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في
قطاع غزه وما رايناه الان من اقتحام للجنه
الماليه في داخل الكنيست الاسرائيلي في
اطار هذا التصعيد للحراك الشعبي من جانب
عائلات الاسر من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام شكرا جزيلا لك